I've covered mostly Wars here I've never  been to a place like this Media who  comes here are only interested in the  war and the positive side the world  never gets to learn about that's why  we're here I'm Bob Woodruff my son Mack  and I are on a big and beautiful  adventure I used to be a war  correspondent until I got wounded blown  up in Iraq but I didn't want my kids to  grow up fearful because of what happened  I'm Mack Woodruff my dad has seen the  worst in some of the world's most  troubled regions and now we're hitting  the road to seek out the best in them  you have to make it bigger just so love  I wanted to connect with people in more  of a real authentic way I love doing  this right now but I love doing this  with you my ten year old self would  probably be pretty jealous so all the  time I get to spend with you now  [Music]